what would you say about the state of
Journalism just on that topic today are
we are we in a temporary kind of uh
uh
are we experiencing a a temporary
problem in terms of the incentives in
terms of the the the business model all
that kind of stuff or is this like a
decline of traditional journalism as we
know it if I always think about the
counterfactual in these things which is
like okay because these questions write
this question heads towards us like okay
the impact of social media and the
undermining of Truth and all this but
then you want to ask the question of
like okay what if we had had the modern
media environment including cable news
and including social media and Twitter
and everything else in 1939 or 1941
writer 1910 or 1865 or 1850 or 1776
right
um and like I think you just introduced
like five thought experiments at once
and broke my head but yes that's there's
a lot of interesting years and we kind
of like kind of I just taken a simple
example can it like how would President
Kennedy have been interpreted it was
what we know now about all the things
Kennedy was up to like how would he have
been experienced by the body of politic
in Us in with the social media context
right like how would LBJ have been
experienced
um by the way how would you know like
many men FDR like the New Deal the Great
Depression I wonder where Twitter would
would just would think about Churchill
and Hitler
and Stalin you know I mean look to this
day they're you know there's there are
lots of very interesting real questions
around like how America you know got you
know basically involved in World War II
and who did what when and the operations
of British intelligence and American
soil and did FDR this that Pearl Harbor
you know yeah Woodrow Wilson ran for you
know his his candidacy was run on an
anti-war we'll you know this he ran the
platform not getting multiple World War
One somehow that switched you know like
and I'm not even making a value judgment
of these things I'm just saying like we
the the way that our ancestors
experienced reality was of course
mediated through centralized top-down
right control at that point
if you if you ran those realities again
with the media environment we have today
the reality would the reality would be
experienced very very differently and
then of course that that intermediation
would cause the feedback loops to change
and then reality would obviously play
out do you think you think it'd be very
different yeah it has to be it has to be
just because it's all so I mean just
look at what's happening today I mean
just I mean the most obvious thing is
just the the collapse and here's another
opportunity to argue that this is not
the internet causing this by the way
um here's a big thing happening today
which is uh Gallup does this thing every
year where they do they pull for trust
in institutions in America and they do
it across all they have everything from
the military to clergy and big business
and the media and so forth right
um and basically there's been a systemic
collapse in trust in institutions in the
US almost without exception uh basically
since essentially the early 1970s
um there's two ways of looking at that
which is oh my God we've lost this whole
world and wish we could trust
institutions and that was so much better
because like that should be the way the
world runs the other way of looking at
it is we just know a lot more now and
the great mystery is why those numbers
aren't all zero yeah right because like
now we know so much about how these
things operating like they're not that
impressive and and also whether we don't
have uh better institutions and better
leaders then yeah and so so this coach
is the thing which is like okay had we
had the media environment of what that
we've had between the 1970s and today if
we had that in the 30s and 40s or 1900s
1910s I think there's no question really
it turned out different if only because
everybody would have known to not trust
the institutions which would have
changed their level of credibility their
ability to control circumstances
therefore the circumstances would have
had to change
right and it would have been a feedback
it was it would have been a feedback
loop process in other words right it's
it's it's it's your experience your
experience of reality changes reality
and then reality changes your experience
of reality right it's it's a two-way
feedback process and media is the
intermediating force between that so
change the media environment change
reality yeah and so it's just so just as
a consequence I think it's just really
hard to say oh things worked a certain
way then and they work a different way
now and then therefore like people were
smarter than or better than or you know
by the way dumber than or not as capable
than right we make all these like really
light and Casual like comparisons of
ourselves to you know previous
generations of people you know we draw
judgments all the time and I just think
it's like really hard to do any of that
because if we if we put ourselves in
their shoes with the media that they had
at that time like I think we probably
most likely would have been just like
them don't you think that our perception
and understanding of reality would you
be more and more mediated through large
language models now so you said media
before
isn't the llm going to be the new what
is it mainstream media MSM it'll be llm
that would be the source of uh I'm sure
there's a way to kind of rapidly
fine-tune like making llms real time I'm
sure there's as probably a research
problem that you can uh do just rapid
fine tuning to the new events so
something like this well even just the
whole concept of the chat UI might not
be the like the chat UI is just the
first whack at this and maybe that's the
dominant thing but look maybe maybe or
maybe we don't we don't know yet like
maybe the experience most people with
LMS is just a continuous feed
you know maybe it's more of a passive
feed and you just are getting a constant
like running commentary on everything
happening in your life and it's just
helping you kind of interpret and
understand everything also really more
deeply integrated into your life not
just like oh uh like intellectual
philosophical thoughts but like
literally
uh like how to make a coffee where to go
for lunch just uh whether you know
dating all this kind of stuff to stay in
a job interview yeah we'll just say yeah
we'll just say next sentence yeah next
sentence yeah at that level yeah I mean
yes so technically now whether we want
that or not is an open question right
well you care for a pop-up a pop-up
right now the estimated engagement using
is decreasing for Mark Henry since
there's a controversy uh section for
this Wikipedia page in 1993 something
happened or something like this bring it
up that will drive engagement up anyway
yeah that's right I mean look this gets
this whole thing of like so you know the
chat interface has this whole concept of
prompt engineering right so yeah well it
turns out one of the things that all of
them are really good at is writing props
right yeah and so like what if you just
outsourced and by the way you could run
this experiment today you can hook this
up to do this today the latency is not
good enough to do it real time in a
conversation but you could you could run
this experiment and you just say look
every 20 seconds you could just say you
know you know tell me what the optimal
prompt is and then ask yourself that
question to give me the result
um and then as as you use you exactly
your point is you add there will be
there will be these systems are going to
have the ability to be learned and
updated essentially in real time and so
you'll be able to have a pendant or your
phone or whatever watch or whatever
it'll have a microphone on it it'll
listen to your conversations it'll have
a feed of everything else happen in the
world and then it'll be you know sort of
retraining prompting or retraining
itself on the Fly um and so the scenario
you described is actually a completely
doable scenario now the hard question on
this is always okay since that's
possible are people going to want that
like what's the form of experience you
know that that we we won't know until we
try it but I don't think it's possible
yet to predict the form of AI in our
lives therefore it's not possible to
predict the way in which it will
intermediate our experience with reality
yet yeah but it feels like there's going
to be a killer app there's probably a
mad scramble right now inside open Ai
and Microsoft and Google in meta and
then startups and smaller companies
figuring out what is the killer app
because it feels like
it's possible like a Chad GPT type of
thing it's possible to build that but
that's 10x more compelling using already
the LOLs we have using even the open
source llms llama and the different
variants
um this is here investing in a lot of
companies and you're paying attention
who do you think is going to win this
you think they'll be
who's gonna be the next page rank
inventor
trillion dollar question
um another one we have a few of those
today a bunch of those so look there's a
really big question today sitting here
today is a really big question about the
big models versus the small models
um that's related directly to the big
question of proprietary versus open
um then there's this big question of of
you know where is the training data kind
of like are we topping out of the
training data or not and then are we
going to be able to synthesize training
data and then there's a huge pile of
questions around regulation
um and you know what's actually going to
be legal um and so I would when we think
about it we'd dovetail kind of all those
All Those Questions together
you can paint a picture of the world
where there's two or three God models
that are just at like staggering scale
um and they're just better at everything
um and they will be owned by a small set
of companies and they will basically
achieve regulatory capture over the
government and they'll have competitive
barriers that will prevent other people
from uh you know competing with them and
so you know there will be you know just
like there's like you know whatever
three big Banks or three big you know or
by the way three big search companies or
I guess two now you know it'll
centralize like that
um you can paint another very different
picture that says no um actually the
opposite of that's going to happen this
is going to basically that this is the
new goal you know this is the new Gold
Rush Alchemy like the thing you know
this is the this is the big bang for
this whole new area of of Science and
Technology and so therefore you're gonna
have every smart 14 year old on the
planet Building open source right you
didn't figure out a ways to optimize
these things
um and then you know we're just gonna
get like overwhelmingly better at
generating trading data if we're gonna
you know bring in like blockchain
networks to have like an economic
incentive to generate decentralized
training data and so forth and so on and
then basically we're going to live in a
world of Open Source and there's going
to be a billion llms right of every size
scale shape and description and there
might be a few big ones that are like
the Super Genius ones but like mostly
what we'll experience is open source and
that's you know that's more like a world
of like what we have today with like
Linux and the web